hi everyone
thank you for taking your time for our
session from cyrus ml to ml service mesh
using api management
kaz sato develop advocate from google
cloud based in tokyo
i'm rakesh talanki i'm google cloud
architect and ipg team
i am an atlanta georgia
in this session we'd like to cover these
topics first i'd like to discuss about
how you can build a scalable machine
running production system
with google cloud's air platform
then i will discuss about the second
problem that is called silo.ml
and how you can solve that by using ml
service mesh
in the latter part of this session
rakesh will discuss about
api management and how it can help
building email service mesh
so let's start discussing about how you
can build a scalable machine running
system with ai platform
now many data scientists or companies
are trying to bring the poc system
into a production machine running system
but those poc or prototypes can be all
covered by a single data scientist
but the for production system you have
to split the responsibility into the
multiple roles
for example data engineer can be
responsible for ingesting the data
from data warehouse and apply some
pre-processing against that
whereas data scientists and ml engineers
can be responsible
for training the model design the
machine running model
get the higher accuracy and they push
the
training model into the system
and then ops engineer or ml engineer can
be responsible for
designing this scalable and continuous
training
training and prediction system
let's think about a scenario where the
data scientist
is visiting a cubicle of the ops teams
to ask
to bring his uh the poc systems into
production system
what kind of the problems the ops team
have to solve
there are many different gaps between
poc and production
for example many plc notebooks can be
locally dependent or dependent on a
single person
but with production system you have to
make everything portable and shareable
and you cannot rely on a single notebook
instance anymore
you have to think about build a cluster
of those multiple instances
with the scaling out or scaling in
functionalities
or load balancing of the incoming
prediction requests
and everything should not be dependent
on the manual process
everything should be reproducible for
the end-to-end machine running life
cycle
and lastly you have to think about
monitoring so that
upstream can be responsible for the
continuous monitoring and enlarging
for the continuous operation
so those are the reason why google
provides a product called cloud ai
platform
that has two features training and
prediction those are managed services
for machine learning training
and prediction for example if you are
using machine learning prediction of
cloud ai platform then you don't have to
spend your time for building a scalable
prediction infrastructure by yourself
instead the managed service can take
care of the adding more instances or
removing the instances
based on the current workload you are
getting for the prediction system
and also it can provide a distributed
gpu and tpu training service
so you can easily get the distributed
the gpu environment without spending
much time on building a gpu cluster
and also the service can provide the
logging features
using the bigquery data warehouse so
that makes
much easier for building a continuous
monitoring setup
so by using cloud ai platform you can
easily get
those benefits required for the scalable
machine learning system
that includes the scheduling of the old
instances
lifecycle management of those continuous
and instances
scaling out and scaling in
functionalities load balancing and
dispatching the workloads
logging monitoring troubleshooting and
security
you don't have to build those features
from from the scratch by yourself
instead
those features are already available in
ai platform
but for the large enterprises that is
not the end of the story
so for example let's imagine a scenario
where you have just
finished building a machine running
pipeline for single service like
recommendation
if it's a large enterprise then you have
to move on to another project
like as optimization then you have to
build another service for detection
demand forecasting customer support
research
and so on so without thinking about
sharing
any intermediate results or assets
you'd easily end up with having multiple
silos of machine running pipeline
that is an anti-pattern called silo.ml
so for example for building a
recommendation system
maybe you are getting the user profile
or user vector from user activities
or product vector from product
description
to train a model for the recommended for
recommendation service
so the solution could be a building a
machine learning service mesh
you could start with building a monolith
kind of this service that
has everything inside it but gradually
you can split your responsibility into
the multiple microservices and
eventually you would have an
a bunch of micro services that can be
easily composed
to build and final the machine learning
service for the
clients or consumers
for example in case of the
recommendation systems rather than
building on the monoliths of the
recommendation systems
but you can split gear those services
into the three micro services
the micro service the ml service a can
predict a user vector
from these activities service b can
predict a
product vector from product description
then you could have another
service c that can take those user
vector and product vector
to provide a recommendation result so
that you can easily reuse
those internal assets like user vectors
and product vector
for the other purposes
so this is a solution called ms service
mesh but the missing link here is the
api management
and why is that because if you are
working for a large enterprises
you have to think about how to share
those assets with a proper business
model and security model
you cannot just you know expose your
apis
without any tracking and monitoring for
that
so missing link here is the api
management for the ml service mesh
so i'd like to pass the screen to rocket
he'll be discussing more about
api management thank you guys
so let's continue with the discussion
where cas stopped
so we have the ml pipelines
you want to introduce them as part of
your enterprise consumption
so how do you go about right you might
have internal consumers
mostly for the ml pipelines it might be
internal consumers
but you might also have the external
consumption the third party where you
don't have ac
where you don't have control right so
the idea here is
how can you take your pipelines or it
can be
other services and make them easily
consumable
by your consumers without any friction
ideally in a self-service mode
right so this is where we're going to
talk about on how to make it happen
most of the companies mostly enterprises
on this journey
moving from monoliths into microservices
right
maybe some companies are halfway through
to service oriented architectures but
still
the journey is going on into breaking
down
monoliths into smaller services well the
idea here is to make your services
fine-grained and make the communication
protocols between these services
lightweight and simple right and also
many of the enterprises are making the
assumption
that the trust is established between
the services
without actually enforcing policies so
the idea of a good
microservices architecture is to
increase
product velocity right you want to
release your features
as often as possible manage complexity
of the code
right and you want to admit
heterogeneity right each developer has
their own tool sets maybe they like
scala some some teams might like
java sometimes might like dotnet right
you want to admit that
and then you want to apply security
policies very very important
you want to enable the trust to
enterprise security policies
and then at the same time you want to
empower your developers
to be as quick as possible and as
independent as possible
so this is how an enterprise
services can look like you have multiple
services
they're all communicating with apis and
by default apis becomes a communication
contract
between services right every system that
can receive requests has some kind of an
epm
they can be restful they can be so or
maybe thousand different ways
of doing apis or maybe they're using
graphql
grpc yaml right so there's a mesh of
services within the enterprise
and then when a consumer from outside of
an inside calls an api
they orchestrate the calls within the
mesh
and get back with a response so we are
getting into some kind of a mesh
here
let's see how to enable this right uh
let's
dig in deep a little bit um we have
service a
we have service b now these are micro
services
how do you enable communications with
them the best way is to
have mutual tls right ideally you want
to have certificates for each of these
services
and once you have unique certificates
you can enable the certificates and
other services
right and you also want to introduce
centrally described communication
policies like you know
retries time out circuit breakers if a
call is taking too long
right you want to enable routing so that
if the services are
located um in different regions
different teams
to enable the routing in efficient way
and on top of it you want to enable
uh authentic authentication
authorization
right maybe not every service is
consumable by every other service so
it's very important
you authorize your services right when
this is happening
you want to collect analytics and also
monitor the services you want to know at
any point in time
whether the service is up or down right
and at the same time you want to enable
some kind of telemetry so that you know
who is consuming what
at any point in time so we need a sort
of a support system to enable this
let us see how to make this happen right
uh so let's delegate all this complexity
of this communication protocols uh to a
standalone
something called envoy right envoy is a
high performance pluggable proxy
providing improved networking and
observability
uh for increased service communication
right so this is built on was built on
learnings from h.a proxy and nginx right
onward is very popularly popular and
widely used
and it's very widely used inside google
also
envoy uses what we call a sidecar
pattern
right in the sidecar pattern uh is
better than embedding different
libraries and making it a big monolith
so with this pattern right it's easier
to support services
implemented in multiple languages and
also
you can update the proxies independent
of other
services right so this is where uh
so this is where a good control plane
will help you
to manage your services
so me as a data scientist at this point
i'm thinking
is this challenging or is this simple
right now a
a model has become part of a mesh
architecture
it's no more a silo right uh so models
are
part of a big big piece in the
enterprise
so let's start uh digging deep now we
want to introduce the control plane
which is a service mesh
right what does uh service mesh help us
to do
right it will help us to connect between
the services
right the flow of traffic between
services it will help to secure the end
points
between the services and encrypt that
communication very very important
right and you want to control this by
applying
security policies right and then you
want to observe and collect metrics
for monitoring and analytics purpose
let's dig in a little bit deep all right
this is
where istio comes into play right istio
starts with the envoy proxy
as a sidecar pattern and then adds a set
of policies to help and manage
and provision the distributed set of
proxies
as you can see in this picture here
right you have the envoy you have the
control plane
and then we'll also introduce what is
called as api management layer here
okay so let us talk to this so how an
api management layer will help you right
you have the services
and you want to enable them both for
internal consumption
and your external consumption and let's
talk to an example
and i'll explain to you on how the api
management layer will help you to do
this
so let's take this example where you
have a legacy app
and you have a monolith app right and
you have your
consumption layer right all these modern
apps you have the legacy apps
and then most of the enterprises have an
api gateway right in this case apigee
api gateway
is a gcp offering to provide you a
full-fledged sas offering to manage
apis most of the enterprises
enable the services to the api layer api
layer kind of acts as a switch
to switch between different services in
the back end
and then you have your internal apps
most places
internal apps are directly going against
your services
there's not much of api management going
on in that layer
now let us go through this journey of
breaking down
a monolith into microservices so let's
take the monolith
or two and break it down into smaller
services
at the same time you're updating the
internal app to consume
your microservices as well as the
monolith and at the same time you're
updating your gateway
to also use the services the new
microservices
and in the process what you're doing is
you're introducing
new capabilities by adding more micro
services
and also you're introducing ml pipelines
right using cloud ml platform uh this is
where you're adding
more capabilities where your internal
apps are being updated
to consume these new capabilities and at
the same time you're keeping it
transparent
for your external consumption to
use the newer capabilities right so
this is as you can see in this the
onset of proliferation of different
services so this is
a problem probably a good problem to
have let us see how we can simplify this
so this is where uh istio control clean
will help you
to build your service mesh architecture
right uh in this
in this diagram you will see uh the
service mesh
is kind of helping to manage the
communication between the services
right you also see
the legacy systems using the legacy
services being
being exposed to the gateway to the
third party system
right and also the internal apps are
using the legacy but at the same time
the internal apps are now using
uh being consuming the services from the
mesh
right and in fact uh the
gateway is acting like a nice little
switch
to switch between the legacy and the
newer layer of mesh architecture
uh you can also see uh what is called as
a rpg adapter
and this is where you get the api
policies
now what does the adapter help you to do
it will help you to centrally govern
uh or manage apis right it enables api
publishing
visibility of the apis right by
publishing them into portals
enables governance good governance by
applying your best practices
and it collects the analytics
specifically from a security perspective
the adapter will help you enforce in the
envoy
like things like verifying the or token
or the api keys
right uh checking if there's enough
authorization to consume the services
right and other things like quota if you
have some kind of a quota on the service
it'll enforce that if you have rate
limiting it will enforce that
uh if you have like threat protection to
validate any threats coming on the apis
it will enforce that so basically uh
adapt is helping you to do these kind of
security policies
right and istio service mesh is helping
you
to enable the communication between the
services this is kind of a clean model
and where the separation of concerns is
very clearly maintained
so let us understand how this is
happening um
so envoy supports a long list of filters
uh and these filters are written in c
plus plus and compiled into
envoy itself right apigee adapter uses a
one specific filter called as
external authorization external auth
filter
which is designed to allow onward to
delegate
authorization decisions to an external
system this is where
apigee is registered and um
and gets the control so let's see how
the traffic flow happens here
so when api call comes into envoy right
uh the onward gives the control to rpg
adapter
right in this case we call it as rpg's
remote service
right um apigee remote service will go
back with either
a or an a right uh so what it will do is
uh it will enforce the policies that the
consumer the api publisher has designed
for this particular api consumption so
it can be over
it can be quotas thread production rate
limiting
any policies they have uh it's enforced
here
if the adapter responds back with the a
then
it will go back to your back end service
uh and then the call is sub
is processed in your backend uh if it is
an a then another is sent back
to your consumer right so apg remote
service is acting as a policy decision
point
um and others to envoy to allow the api
consumption or not
now how does this work in a very high
performing system how can you get those
hundreds and thousands of
tps in api call right so the first the
communication between
the proxy and the apigee remote services
grpc
so this is very good for speed and
efficiency right
and then the apg remote service talks to
its management plane
and downloads anything that is required
to make the decision
which includes the policies right keys
products anything that's required it's
all cached inside the remote service
so this is how you can this is how the
apigee remote service is built
for a high performance support system
so let's try to bring everything
together so why
use api management in your service mesh
right so you don't want any of your
services to be in a silo
right whether it is your
cloud air prediction models or whether
it can be a micro
service uh it can be anything it needs
to be discovered
and how do you discover them so with
apigee you can have a portal
where you can publish all your services
right
and this portal can be designed in a way
that the consumers
can act in a self-service way uh there's
no more
white listing of firewalls uh or
whitelisting
your apis right someone can come and say
i need access to certain apis
and then your api producer can get a
request
and then they can upload the request
right
and then you can modernize your services
all
all the stuff on the legacy your old
monolith applications everything can be
hidden by nice little apis using rest or
any standards that you use
and expose them in a good way right
and then no more exchanging those pdf
files or word files
right you can have nice documentation
wherein you give the required
technical aspects for the api and the
consumer can come in and try those apis
before even
they use it in the application right and
then you can have
reports on the services this is very
very critical
at any point you should be able to
answer the questions like uh
who are my top five consumers right or
what are my slas
that were satisfied today or what was my
performance
right uh what kind of products we use
from a business aspect
so you can you should be able to answer
these kind of questions using the
analytics that you covered
and in a large enterprise governance
becomes very very important
right you want some kind of best
practices enforced across the teams
and this is critical you can enforce
things like ci cd
linting right code standards all these
kinds of things
occurs enterprise you can enable and
enforce them
right once you have the apis it's very
very critical
you monitor them at any point you should
know which services are
or which service is slowing down before
your consumers tell you which is very
very important
and then once you have this nice little
system working
you want to start making money out of it
you want to accept a credit card
and start charging your consumer members
and this is where the monetization
module in rpg comes into picture you can
plug it in
and define your policies on how to
monetize your apis maybe not all aps
need to be monetized maybe you pick
a few business apis which are critical
uh you only monetize a certain set of
apis these
kind of uh behaviors can be brought in
with a good ap management layer
so we have a solution page uh which ties
up all this
and you should be able to try it uh
build a prediction model in the cloud
air platform and then
expose that air ai model using the rpg
engine
and then send it to your consumers so
all this in a frictionless way
we have a solution page explaining all
of this
i would say the biggest takeaway for you
in this session will be
once you have these models how can you
models or other services
how can you make your consumption of
these services
uh seamless frictionless right you want
the consumption to be the easiest of all
so that your services are actually
consumed
a lot faster giving the benefit to the
enterprise right the impact is a lot
more faster if you
remove those kinds of friction so the
biggest takeaway will be
how do you bring in your services in a
way
that can be consumed without any
friction
looking ahead
we have a solution page where you can
try this
sample example where you can try the ai
platform and apigee we have step-by-step
instructions
you can get a free free trial account
uh you get almost all the features in a
sas platform you can try it out
uh we have a very good community a lot
of questions have been asked and
answered if you have more questions feel
free to answer
ask there one of us will answer that
and if you need to reach one of us for
more
discussion feel free to reach out either
cash on me we'll be happy to help you
out
if you need more information contact us
one of us will get in touch with you
thank you again for joining us
have a great day